die bilder vom transport des vergifteten
kreml kritikers alexej nawalny ging um
die welt
einmal von omsk zur charité nach berlin
und das mit einem prominenten patienten
der im koma lag
möglich gemacht hat es eine challenger
604 des nürnberger unternehmens flight
ambulance institution wir haben einen
exklusiven einblick der high tech
ausrüstung bekommen transportiert wurden
aber nie in einer isolations war ein
transport fähiges krankenbett mit einem
plexiglas gehäuse luftzirkulation
defibrillator und ekg machen die mobile
intensivstation perfekt eine sogenannte
mobile isolations anhalt zum transport
von hoch infektiösen patienten oder wie
man es vielleicht jetzt auch in dem fall
navalny kennt auch von patienten wohl
nicht hundertprozentig weiß ob sie
vergiftet worden sind hintergrund dieser
situation heute ist einfach dass man
versucht sowohl den patienten als auch
die personen die den patienten betreuen
also die mediziner zu schützen
im falle der wahl nachdem man ist ja
nicht wusste wer ist natürlich für ein
hohes risiko für die mediziner gewesen
dass es sich vielleicht auch mit
irgendwas vergiften
deswegen ist während diese isolation
seien halt geflogen worden
der transport ende august des berühmten
patienten verlief reibungslos
das nürnberger unternehmen ist derzeit
mit ihren insgesamt fünf maschinen
regelmäßig unterwegs
geradezu coroner zeiten sind die
speziell ausgestatteten maschinen sehr
gefragt eben für den sicheren transport
infektiöser patienten und das in
kürzester zeit
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren